[музика]
це Європа У фокусі я Лара баба Лола
Ласкаво просимо
Румунія входить до числа найгірших країн
членів ЄС у питанніх переробки відходів
переважна більшість сміття та вторинної
сировини змішується Іще до того як
потрапляє на звалище
це порушує стандарти Євросоюзу який
виділив Румунії гроші на належне
управління відходами заключає в себе
будівництво сучасного сміттєвого
майданчика у місті клуш але наша
кореспондентка виявила що мільйонні
кошти ЄС не допомогли вирішити цю
проблему
румунське сміттєзвалище повне не
сортованих відходів профінансоване
грішми Євросоюзу це мало бути сучасним
екологічно чистим сміттєзвалищем замість
старого нелегального сміттєзвалища
поблизу міста Лужна Пока Яке
десятиліттями гуляло око
нове сміттєзвалище відкрилося після
тривалої затримки але здається мало що
змінилося на краще сюди все ще скидають
на сортоване сміття нічого не
переробляється шкідлива практика
заборонена в ЄС
Ми хочемо з'ясувати що тут пішло не так
у житловому районі ми дивимося на
початок сміттєвого ланцюга перше
враження позитивне є різні баки для
різних відходів
ви сортуєте сміття коли як іноді це
немає сенсу бо сміття забирає одна
машина це насправді не переробка все
одно все забирає одна машина
а потім це відбувається на наших очах
навантажівці написано Сьогодні ми
збираємо папір але забирають і все інше
з усіх баків
[музика]
це поодинокий випадок Чи це системна
проблема
Ми зустрічаємося із шандором кроссвоєм
який працює у сфері переробки відходів а
він також активісти стежить за тим що
роблять збирачі відходів у клузі
Отже Що відбувається зараз схоже вони
знову збирають різні типи відходів так
так
здається вони змішують сміття з усіх
баків Так на жаль
Румунія переробляє лише 14% своїх
муніципальних відходів тоді як середній
показник поїздів становить 49%. шандор
куросфой каже що це частково пов’язане
із румунською системою Зборів
зараз збір вторинної сировини обходиться
дорожче ніж збір змішаних відходів
їх окремо
разом із шандором кореспоєм та трьома
іншими екоактивістами я переглядаю відео
з нового сміттєпереробного заводу зняти
за допомогою дрона активісти занепокоєні
тим що майданчик заповнюється швидше ніж
мавпи до того ж не сортованими відходами
А це незаконно в ЄС
це не одномоментна помилка а структурна
проблема Як ви можете бачити з площі яка
вкрита неочищеним несортованим сміттям
більшість матеріалів вони не
переробляють не сортують а просто
викидають туди Це абсолютно очевидно
із 2014-го по 2020 рік ЄС витратив 318
мільйонів євро субсидій на управління
відходами в Румунії 40 мільйонів тільки
на містоклуш ми хотіли поговорити з
людьми відповідальними за вивезення
відходів але ні компанії Що займається
вивезенням відходів ні Міністерство
європейських інвестицій Румунії не
відповіли на наш запит
місцева асоціація з управління відходами
усе ж письмово повідомила нам що в разі
виявлення недоліків вони накладуть
штрафні санкції
за реалізацією проекту ЄС тут відповідає
районна рада ми зустрілися із її
речником який каже що в клузі немає
проблеми зі сміттям
некомформе ми закрили всі громадські
звалищі які не відповідають вимогам і
ввели в експлуатацію новий майданчик і
Центр інтегровано управління відходами
це безумовний успіх
Ми помітили що сміття в кожі досі не
переробляється і не збирається окремо
це одна з головних цілей європейських
стандартів управління відходами
вас як місцеву владу клужу це не турбує
можливо є якісь поодинокі проблеми
але я кажу вам як жити що це точно не
систематична проблема
здається
ніг на те що проблема відходів тут існує
тож Ми вирушаємо до брюсселя щоб
запитати що з цим робить Європейська
комісія яка фінансувала більшу частину
системи утилізації відходів у Румунії
комісія не керує проектами ми не стежимо
за кожним окремим проектом за попередній
період у нас було півтора мільйона
проектів чи навіть більше
профінансованих У рамках політики
згуртованості і всі вони управляються
державами-членами у Румунії здається
ніхто не хоче брати на себе
відповідальність на превеликий жаль для
іштвана сакаца Він встановлює камеру
спостереження біля сміттєзвалища щоб
відстежувати що саме туди викидають
чоловік планує подати скаргу до
Європейського бюро із боротьби з
шахрайством але він не надто
оптимістичний
поки Європа задовольняється
pdf-файликами а саме так було є і буде
Румунія буде І далі без проблем робити
нові й нові красиві pdf-файлики
[музика]
нам не вдалося з'ясувати хто
відповідальний за безладу клужі Але
можливо в цьому і є корінь проблеми у
хлопку європейських проектів Кожен хоче
отримати свій Шматок пирога але здається
ніхто не хоче брати на себе повну
відповідальність Ані за відходи Ані за
те Куди йдуть гроші
почався зворотній відлік менш ніж за рік
Париж прийматиме Літні Олімпійські ігри
еліта плавання з усього світу
змагатиметься за золотом і кілька їхніх
запливів відбудуться у сині але річка що
протікає через французьку столицю не
зовсім безпечна якість її води історична
була поганою 100 років тому була видана
сувора заборона на купання в сині але
місто хоче взяти цю проблему під
контроль до 2024 року і вони занурюються
в роботу щоб вкластися в терміни
сьогодні вранці на сцені все ще тихо
паризьке річкова поліція яка наглядає за
річкою 24/7 вийшла на патрулювання
бригаду очолює командирка Софі малярбе
для неї сцена наче місто зі своїми
мешканцями трафіком і правилами
тут купатися суворо заборонено
заборонено бо тут надто багато небезпек
і є ризик потонути
[музика]
це було заборонено протягом 100 років
але завдяки олімпійським іграм є амбітні
плани Знову дозволити купання у Сені
найбільший спортивний парк будь колись
проектований у місті
включає в себе 160-метрову плавучу
легкоатлетичну доріжку та дивовижні
споруди встановлені на найвідоміших
пам'ятках міста в тому числі на річці
сцена
[музика]
Ліонель чекає з нетерпінням
він живе на сцені у затишному плавучому
будинку
чоловік планує спостерігати за церемонію
відкриття Олімпійських ігор наступного
року зі своєї тераси наживо і зблизька
зі свого місця у першому ряду
ось якось так це буде Мої друзі теж
будуть тут і ми будемо насолоджуватися
цим разом
ми будемо зовсім близько я точно планую
отримати максимум задоволення від цієї
події
Він показує звідки сотні тисяч людей
спостерігатимуть за подіями з берега
річки і деякі водні спортивні змагання
проходитимуть Саме тут
день анжелеско фізіолог який вже 5 років
працює на паризьку владу і тестує якість
води у сеніна на наявність
бактеріального забруднення
велике питання полягає у тому чи буде
річка достатньо чистою для проведення
Ігор і чи дозволять спортсменам
занурюватися у воду
Я думаю що це буде можливо
зимове регулярних і належних заходів для
забезпечення якості води
Ми не збираємося наражати людей на
небезпеку наші проби будуть
підтверджувати якість води
щоб докопатися до суті ми спускаємося
глибоко у Надра Парижа під річку у
каналізацію
у французькій столиці понад тисячу
кілометрів каналізаційних труб які
збирають дощову та стічну воду
коли випадають сильні дощі каналізація
яка була побудована ще за часів
Наполеона першого переповнюється
десятиліттями під час злив буду
відводили прямо в річку
без будь-якого очищення не дивно що
людям заборонено купатися у Сені
це зміниться завдяки новій надсучасній
системі очищення води яка зараз
будується у центрі міста
але Попереду ще багато роботи
у цьому передмісті Всього за 200 метрів
від Парижа досі є багато будинків не
підключених до міської каналізації
тут уже кілька тижнів тривають роботи з
прокладання нових труб для близько 35
тисяч домогосподарств
[музика]
Жан Філіп показує нам свою нову систему
тепер усі труби з'єднані
з кухні з туалетів із ванни
і йому не довелося нічого платити Тому
що мені це політет покрив витрати з
бюджету на проведення Олімпійських ігор
Звісно це відіграє свою роль місто хочу
показати що воно має функціонуючу
систему водовідведення
зараз на сцені розпал сезону і повсюди
йде підготовка до олімпіади
капітан девалуа і його річковий човен
були обрані для великої місії
його човен буде серед 16 суден які
пройдуть сценою під час церемонії
відкриття
Він дуже радий
Звісно я дуже пишаюся це велика подія
масштабна подія для Парижа і амбітна
модернізація для сцени
а занадто часто смерть - це тема табу
про яку мало хто хоче говорити Регіна
ціряк невиліковно хвора але Регіна
відчуває що не може вільно і відкрито
говорити про це зі своєю родиною замість
цього вона покладається на цю жінку
Мартіну букат вона досвідчена
компаньйонка для тих чиє життя добігає
кінця і спеціалізується на тому щоб
мінімізувати страх пов'язаний зі смертю
секундочку Так
я маю бути в цьому щонайменше шість
годин уночі
кисневий апарат діє на нерви регіні
ціряк але вона невиліковна хвора з
останньою стадією ХОЗЛ невиліковного
захворювання легенів у неї залишилося
всього 20% життєвої ємності легенів і ця
цифра зменшується без додаткового кисню
вона практично безпорадна
ну для мене це завжди стрес тому що в
мене клаустрофобія і коли в тебе
постійно щось перед обличчям це не
приємно
Регіна хоче підготуватися до власної
смерті саме тому раз на тиждень до неї
заходить мартінна букет вона волонтерка
мальтезер International як компаньйонка
для людей чиє життя добігає кінця Вона
вже супроводжувала більше десяти людей
розмови з нею полегшують страх руїни
перед смертю вони є досвід і вона
говорить зі мною відверто і Це додає
мені сміливості сама по собі ця тема
нескладна складно те як люди до неї
ставляться ми можемо дуже спокійно
ставитись до цього говоримо про все це
не з усіма Можливо але з регіною працює
чудово вони у двох також дуже відкрито
говорять про похорон Я хотіла б щоб мій
прах розкидали у горах Це було б важливо
для мене і ще велику вечірку але не
вечірку смерті а вечірку життя щоб усі
мої друзі святкували життя а не смерть
Ось чого я б хотіла
Мартіна пройшла дев'ятимісячний курс
навчання на компаньйона у мальтезерс там
Вона навчилася тримати професійну
дистанцію але з регіною це не легко
вона така сердечна людина повністю
усвідомлює свою ситуацію але водночас
Така позитивна вона дає мені енергію і я
навіть не уявляю звідки вона її бере але
це просто чудово через кілька тижнів ми
повернулися до Регіни Вона живе з
чоловіком у мансардній квартирі без
балкона в Берліні навіть просто вийти з
дому це величезні зусилля чоловік
допомагає їй вони витрачають цілу
вічність Щоб спуститися на три поверхи
вниз
Регіна може ходити лише на короткі
відстані але подорож до лавки перед
будинком це особлива подія
вона одружена зі своїм чоловіком уже 40
років і може покластися на нього та
їхніх двох дітей але вона не може
говорити з ним про свою смерть так само
відкритою легко як з мартіною
Мартіна вже чекає на кухні сьогодні вони
говоритимуть про те чи поїде Регіна
незабаром до хоспісу знаєте я сказала що
якщо я все ще здатна обирати якщо я все
ще при цьому щоб зробити цей вибір
самостійно то це чудово інші ходять на
недільні прогулянки А я сказала Давай
поїдемо до хоспісу через два місяці на
початку грудня вони поїхали туди чоловік
країни вольганг підтримує її і
супроводжує дохоспису хоче хотів би щоб
вона залишилася вдома але Регіна має
власну думку і все це було обговорено із
мартіною
Після кількох обговорень у тому числі з
моєю компаньйонкою з мальтезер я
вирішила що буде краще якщо моя сім'я не
братиме в цьому безпосередньої участі
не думаю що їм буде приємно бачити як
їхню матір виносити мит ногами вперед
три місяці потому Регіна досі вдома але
вона перебралася в центральну вітальню
Ось моє нове лікарняне ліжко Я
переселилася
то трохи світліша трохи приємніше
Тут я можу приймати відвідувачів Усе
чудово
а її чоловік на відстані одного
натискання кнопки
Це мій дзвіночок для прислуги
її чоловік тепер працює з дому щоб мати
змогу доглядати за нею переїзд до
хоспісу вони поки що відклали
я бачу що Ви наші цілком добре
справляється вдома Якщо їй допомагати
і мені краще що вона була тут аніж
цілими днями сидіти на самоті і ходити
до неї тільки в гості я готовий прийняти
те що до мене більше не ставляться як до
чоловіка а як до прислуги
твій чайові отримуєш
Приблизно через два тижні після цього
візиту Регіна раптово померла спокійно
як вона і хотіла
Мартіна букац одягає вечірнє вбрання на
прощання з регіною як вона того і хотіла
і вечірка саме така якою її уявляла собі
Регіна
гучно жваво-барвистом Саме так ми
домовлялися і саме так воно і вийшло
а не Великдень родина виконує останнє
побажання Регіни вони розвіюють її прах
у швейцарських горах
[музика]
один посту соціальних мережах може
змінити життя так сталося з Сашою
шуняком який народився синдромом Дауна
пост в інтернеті викликав цілу хвилю
солідарності і вдихнув нове життя в кафе
де він працює Воно знаходиться в
боснійському містечку Тузла Це кафе
унікальне в ньому працюють люди із
особливостями і вони дуже віддані своїй
роботі тому коли поширилися чутки про те
що кафе може закритися громада
згуртувалась
для Саші шуняка його робота - це все
він майже щодня працює у кафе клуб
змієво серця або клуб Серце дракона і
усе що серце бійця він не здається
навіть коли стає важко
я такий щасливий
я сповнений радості
Я люблю працювати тут і завжди буду
любити
я міг би працювати тут 24 години без
перерви
його колега борівську суму віч не може
говорити але безумовно підтримав би цю
ідею Він навіть хотів би поставити у
кафе ліжку щоб ночувати там
обом пощастило у Боснії майже немає
роботи для людей із синдромом Дауна Хоча
багато хто з них має диплом
професійно-технічного училища наприклад
гастрономічного
цей проект кафе єдиний у своєму роді у
Боснії
обличчях та обличчях їхніх родин видно
що кафе стало для них другою домівкою
кажуть що вони ніколи не бачили своїх
дітей щасливішими
проект був фактично на межі провалу люди
і з особливостями досі стикаються з
проблемами інклюзії у Боснії
у перші кілька місяців майже не було
гостей кафе по сусідству були заповнені
під зав'язку але не Серце дракона
тут бувало лише едіма ефендіч дініч
письменниця знає Сашу з дитинства Вона
відвідує його у кафе Майже щодня однієї
суботи кілька тижнів тому вона була
єдиною гостею і Омер її сфотографував
я не знала що Омер в мене сфотографував
ми сиділи розмовляли і він сказав що
збирається написати що клуб закривається
в кінці місяця я сказала Та ну не треба
до цього не дійде а він сказав що ми не
зможемо пережити це фінансово
знак у наших поста нашої області після
нашого посту все змінилося
спочатку про це написали регіональні
зміни
потім про це заговорили на всю країну
враз у нас була повна посадка зранку до
вечора
тут не можна було знайти вільного
столика
кажуть це було диво відтоді справи у
кав'ярні йдуть чудово гості не стримують
своїх похвал
кажу вам це одна з найкращих кав'ярень
чисто охайно майже педантично чисто
і обслуговування на найвищому рівні
з початку я була дуже здивована я просто
не очікувала але насправді немає ніякої
різниці Я думаю що вони навіть
ставляться до мене та інших і збільшує
повагою привітністю ніж деінде
подібні проекти плануються відкрити і в
інших місцях
кафе Серце дракона це лише початок але
дуже багато обіцяючий
цікавинка для любителів піших прогулянок
у швейцарських Альпах один із найдовших
у світі пішохідних підвісних мостів це
крутий шлях угору не для людей зі
слабкими нервами але на тих хто
перетинає місто Чарльза конина чекає
винагорода захоплюючи вид на Альпи вид
під мостом також перехоплює подих
настільки що деякі туристи вирішують
повернутися назад
цією стежкою Ви точно не заблукаєте а на
цьому Ми завершуємо випуск програми
Європа У фокусі цього тижня Дякуємо за
перегляд і до зустрічі
[музика]